we've seen multiple times in our life
that distance couldn't be viewed as rate
times time and what I want to do in this
video is use this fairly simple formula
right over here this fairly simple
equation to understand that units can
really be viewed as algebraic objects
that you can kind of treat them like
variables as we work through a formula
or equation which could be really really
helpful to make sure that our that we're
getting results in units that actually
make sense so for example if someone
were to give you a rate if they were to
say a rate of let's say five meters per
second and they were to give you a time
a time of 10 seconds then we can pretty
in a pretty straightforward way apply
this formula we say well distance is
equal to our rate five meters per second
times our time times our time which is
ten seconds and what's neat here is we
can treat the units as I just said like
algebraic constructs kind of like
variables so this would be equal to well
multiplication doesn't matter what order
we multiply in so we can change the
order this is the same thing as 5 times
10 five times 10 times meters per second
times meters per second times seconds
times seconds and if we were to treat
our units as these kind of algebraic
objects so excited look we have seconds
divided by seconds or you have a seconds
in the denominator multiplied by seconds
in the numerator those are going to
cancel out and 5 times 10 of course is 5
times 10 of course is 50 so we would be
left with 50 and the units that we're
left with are the meters 50 meters so
that's pretty neat the unit's worked out
when we treated the unit's out like
algebraic objects they worked out so
that our end units for distance were in
meters which is a unit of distance now
you're saying okay that's that's cute
and everything but this seems like a
little bit of too much overhead to worry
about when I'm just
doing a simple formula like this but
what I want to show you is that even
with this simple with a simple formula
like distance is equal to rate times
time what I just did could actually be
quite useful and this thing that I'm
doing is actually called dimensional
analysis and it's useful for something
as simple as distance equals rate times
time but as you go into physics and
chemistry and engineering you'll see
much much much more I would say hairy
formulas and when you do the dimensional
analysis it makes sure that your that
the math is working out right and make
sure that you're getting the right units
but even with this let's try a slightly
more complicated example let's say that
our rate is let's say let's keep our
rate at 5 meters per second but let's
say that someone gave us the time
instead of giving it in seconds they
give it in hours so they say the time is
equal to 1 hour so now let's try to
apply this formula so we're going to get
distance is equal to 5 meters per second
5 meters per second times time which is
1 hour times 1 hour well what's that
going to give us well the 5 times the 1
so we multiply the 5 times the 1 that's
just going to give us 5 but then we have
to remember we have to cheat the unit's
algebraically we're going to do our
dimensional analysis so it's 5 so we
have meters per second times hours times
hours or you could say 5 meter hours per
second well this doesn't look like a
this isn't a set of units that we know
that that makes sense to us this doesn't
feel like our traditional units of
distance so we want to cancel this out
in some way and it might jump out of you
oh if we can get rid of this hours if we
can express it in terms of seconds then
that would cancel here and we'd be left
with just the meters which is a unit of
distance that we're familiar with so how
do we do that well we want to multiply
this thing by something that has hours
in the denominator and seconds in the
numerator times essentially seconds per
hour
well how many seconds are there per hour
well there are 3600 let me do the sunna
I'll do it in this color there are 3,600
seconds per hour or you could even say
that there are 3600 seconds for every
one hour so when you now when you
multiply these hours will cancel with
these hours these seconds will cancel
with those seconds and we are left with
we are left with five times 3,600 what
is that that's five times 3000 would be
fifteen thousand five times 600 is
another three thousand so that is it's
equal to eighteen thousand and the only
units that were left with we just have
the meters there eighteen oh eighteen
thousand eighteen thousand eighteen
thousand meters but and so this is we're
done we've now expressed our distance in
terms of units that we recognize if you
go five meters per second for one hour
you will go 18,000 meters but let's just
use our little dimensional analysis
muscles a little bit more what if what
if we didn't want the answer in meters
but we wanted the answer in kilometers
what could we do well we could take that
18,000 meters 18,000 meters and if we
could multiply it by something that has
meters in the denominator meters in the
denominator and kilometers in the
numerator then these meters would cancel
out and we'd be left with the kilometers
so what can we multiply it so we're not
really changing the value well we want
to multiply it by essentially one so we
want to write equivalent things in the
numerator in the denominator so one
kilometer is equivalent to equivalent to
1000 meters so one way to think about it
we're just multiplying this thing by one
one kilometer over a thousand meters
well one kilometer is a thousand meters
so this thing is equivalent to one but
what's neat is when you multiply we have
meters cancelling with meters and so
you're left with 18,000 divided by 1,000
is equal to 18 and then the only units
were left with is the kilometers and we
are done we have re expressed our
distance instead of in meters in terms
of kilometers